peaceful peaceful peaceful peace be unto
you welcome to another episode of the
deans show can TV 36 Wednesdays at
midnight Thursdays at 2 p.m. and if you
miss us on the TV here in Chicago don't
worry about it you can catch us as
people do all around the globe at the
Dean show.com well we're here trying to
help you understand Islam and Muslims
now my next guest is going to come out
to talk about some of the common
holidays it's the season to get jolly
and during these times people do all
sorts of things so we're going to be
talking about some of the origins where
some of these holidays came from so when
we come back we're gonna get enlightened
God willing with our next guest Abdul
Hakim quick here on the Deen show you
don't want to go nowhere
Herman is his messenger Allah you know
him
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
is just to break the ice
assalamo allaikum well he comes in I
want to lie for anonymous and guests
they want to know what we said so they
don't have to take an Arabic class
please tell us we said peace be upon you
and that is the greetings of peace and I
pray that all those who watch this
program can find peace in their life and
their society
is it just coincidence or did Jesus
Moses and the last in front of us and do
they greet their followers of this
greeting of peace yes this is the
greetings of all of the prophets and
people of consciousness and wise people
all over the planet begin with a state
of peace as that is where we come from
and hopefully that is where we go now
you're our teacher you're our Shaykh
I've personally been learning from you I
mean you started studying probably when
I was born so you've really been around
you've been helping to clear many of the
misconceptions you actually weren't
Muslim you accepted Islam you used to be
a Christian that's right
can you just tell us briefly how you
came to Islam smile ar-rahman rahim in
the name of allah the beneficent the
merciful i was born and raised in Boston
Massachusetts and with mixed parentage
and I was basically raised as an
african-american however I do have some
European background and also some Native
American background them from the Mohawk
tribe so from a young age I question my
own identity and I questioned the things
around me and I was raised in a
Christian family we were First Baptist
and then we became Episcopalians that's
closer to Catholic yeah of course
and I questioned certain sights and
symbols and what I was learning was in
the church itself and I was raised in
the turbulent 60s and the 60s the Age of
Aquarius young people were very
rebellious and questioning and so I
myself was part of that group
and I wanted to know what the background
was to information that was being given
to me so I became a student of history
and I consider that to be my love to go
into history which really gives the
background to things that we see today
because if people do not know where they
come from then they can't fully
understand where they are and they'll be
confused where they're going
so therefore history gives a background
or a basis to what we we face in life
and I began to go into this and focus on
you know all the different things I was
being taught and then finally this is
not the show where we're talking about
your journey to saw God willing
hopefully we'll get to go in some of the
details and on another episode but
finally you ended up coming to that way
the way of all the prophets that we have
surrender and submission and not to
anything in the creation but to the
creator of the heavens and earth
something with one word Islam yes
eventually I did leave the church
I didn't leave my belief in God or my
respect for Jesus and Mary peace be upon
them and I used to read the Lord's
Prayer I used to love that prayer yeah
and I would always read the Lord's
Prayer and focus on the fact of you know
the Father the creator of the heavens
and the earth and so even though I was
disillusioned with the institutionalized
church I was not disillusioned disand
you know disillusioned with God or with
the respect for the prophets so I
continued my journey until I came across
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
and I found that he was the continuation
of the message and the fulfillment of
what Jesus was talking about when he
spoke about a comforter so this was
something which really completed my
religious understanding and really
helped me to get a worldview and to
respect all of the prophets not one or
two but all of the prophets who came to
teach monotheism then this is amazing
how you are searching for the truth and
you know when you want it is there you
don't want to want it that's right so
tell us now these common holidays and I
actually saw your lecture on the origins
of the common holidays Christmas Easter
Valentimes and I think when people get
to know some of the roots of where these
originated from it's very enlightening
yeah so why don't we start with
Christmas can you talk a little bit to
us about Christmas well I think it's
important to get a background for all of
the holidays yes because what I found
out is that from the from early times
there were people who worshiped the
creation itself so yeah they would take
different aspects of the creation if
they live by a river yeah then the river
was God if they lived in a desert with
big rocks then they would worship around
the rocks probably the most important
god of the ancient world was the Sun so
the Sun God became the symbol of power
and authority and in Europe as an other
many parts of the world they would
structure their holidays and structure
their in their religion around seasons
yeah so they would focus on vegetation
the growth of educate vegetation also
that the Sun how the Sun moves and so
you would find in different seasons or
the Meridian the point that they call
solstice so you have that middle point
in the winter the winter solstice you
have the spring solstice the summer in
the fall so it was right at the Solstice
point that special ceremonies are were
happening in the ancient world and it
was in the winter solstice especially in
the northern countries that they would
celebrate the the the conquests or the
or the coming returning of the Sun
because around December 22nd or so this
is like the longest day and then it goes
in by December 25th now it's changing
back and so in many northern countries
where it's very cold it was dangerous to
be living during the winter people would
die yeah cuz they didn't have central
heating and whatnot and and then and if
you really found North in December the
Sun goes away from maybe 20 20 days
sometimes a whole
it's dark outside so they would
literally light bonfires and they would
make certain idols and have special
symbols in order to bring the sun-god
back yeah and so these ceremonies were
developed in the north based upon you
know that the coming back of the Sun and
in Greece and in Rome they celebrated
what it's called the Bacchanalia for the
father god of wine and play back us
yeah and the Greeks and the Romans had
they had the Saturnalia which was for
Saturn and and this is like the god of
time the Sun God and so special
ceremonies were held at that time where
they would make sacrifices and they
would have certain symbols and even the
Romans I it was reported that they would
sacrifice many of the early Christians
when Christianity or the followers of
Jesus peace be upon him came into Rome
they would sacrifice them to the Lions
and and whatnot
and so when Christianity when the
teachings finally became strong in Rome
they no longer sacrifice people but then
on that December 25th they had gave out
little dolls and they would say to each
other
buona Saturnalia which means like today
we would say Merry Christmas yeah bonus
bonus eternally set scenario which mean
yeah which is have a good Saturnalia
which is the the holiday on December
25th and around their Coliseum's they
would put lights so the light concept
around the building that was there in
ancient times also in the northern
countries they would bring the fir tree
into the house because the fir tree was
the only living thing in in the cold
countries and so they figured that there
must be some power that this tree has so
they wanted that spiritual power in
their house in order to protect them
from evil and give them good give them
health so they would bring in the fir
tree and they would put a light on the
top of it that represented the Sun God
and so all of these symbols the
mistletoe and holly and all of these
symbols were actually from the ancient
world I was really surprised to find out
when I visited anxious Egypt you find in
in the ancient times they had what is
called the
and that is like a cross with a loop on
the top and that was the original cross
so the cross was a symbol in the ancient
world that stood for eternal life and so
when the followers of Jesus peace be
upon him when they came into that area
and they were suffering and they
couldn't take the pain so somebody must
have made the decision if you can't beat
them join them
and so an amalgamation of the two
religions came about and so they
celebrated the birth of Christ on the
December twenty-fifth and when actually
the the religious historians will tell
you that Jesus peace upon him was not
born in the winter because even
according to the Christian traditions
yeah the the the flocks were being were
outside the revealed and did the
maintenance of a flocks
inside because cold in Palestine yeah so
for your flocks to be outside means that
it was warm outside also Joseph and Mary
who paid their taxes to the government
and the taxes is ripe fruit and that
happens in the warm weather yeah the
Quran itself the book of Scripture of
the Muslims talks about Mary may Allah
be pleased with her that she in her
pregnancy at the end of it that she was
told to go out to the palm tree and she
should shake this Nakhla this ripe dates
would have come down and so the ripened
dates we know come in August it's in the
heat of the summer so all religious
traditions show that Jesus was born in
the warm weather but in order to make
the religion fair-seeming to the nature
worshippers they incorporated the birth
of Jesus at the time of the winter
solstice so this is where Christmas
originally begins now the the the main
character and Christmas today for most
people is not really Jesus only for
religious people the main character is
Santa Claus
yeah and Santa Claus really many people
believe and you'll see a number of books
that are written he is like the image of
Saturn because there's a picture of
Saturn that was done in the Sistine
Chapel and he's a well-built man with a
beard
and he's on a sleigh but he has snakes
with wings yeah so that's similar to a
sleigh with the reindeers
I don't normally fly but they're pullin
Santa Claus around
it's like Saturn yeah similarly the
whole name
st. Nicholas or Saint Nick Nicholas
himself was a bishop who lived in
Constantinople in what is now Turkey and
he was a very austere person he used to
fast and he was very different than the
jolly merry santa claus that we know of
that's a different image altogether
I was shocked even more to find out that
in Germany they actually considered
Saint Nicholas to be the devil he was
dressed in red and you can go in their
traditions and they considered him to be
a dangerous person they would say to
their children don't go outside in the
winter because Nicholas will get you you
see and so this is why up until 1647 the
British Parliament banned Christmas yeah
in England it was against the law to
celebrate Christmas because they
considered it to be a satanic type of
thing yeah a nature worship thing not a
Christian ceremony so therefore so this
is what started me to think that really
you know something's going on and we
have to become detectives to really
separate monotheism from polytheism to
separate nation worship nature worship
from the worship of one God I took it a
step further yeah when the spring
solstice came this was the time of the
return of life life after death because
in the northern countries that's the
time when the trees and plants that have
died then become green and so the
ancient nature worshippers in in
Northern Europe they had a goddess call
Austria or Austin or what we now call
Easter so they believed she was a
goddess tan she waved her wand and
everything turns green yeah so the bunny
rabbits and the eggs and chickens and
flowers and all these symbols of Easter
have nothing to do with Jesus peace be
upon him because Jesus was Jewish he was
following the law of Moses so these have
nothing to do with Jesus
egg is the symbol of life and the rabbit
is a symbol of fertility because the
rabbit is one of the most productive
mammals in terms of having babies so all
of these are really fertility symbols so
it's a fertility nature cult and so they
incorporated life after death meaning
spring after winter they mix that with
the concept of resurrection of life
after death yeah so they amalgamated the
two and that's the reason why Christians
today say Easter when actually that was
not a Christian ceremony or a Jewish
ceremony that was a pagan nature worship
so all of it's mixed up together today
and this is what we have to do to
separate the two I took it a step
further yeah and then we found Halloween
Halloween is coming in at a time it is
really the celebration of Samhain who
was you know the god of evil and the
underworld and so it was a underworld
cult as well and Halloween is actually a
time of evil and a time when they
believed that the spirits of the Dead
would rise to the surface and they would
come to people's homes and they would
haunt them and so the people used to
wear a mask they would mask their face
so if there was a ghost or a spirit that
had wanted to take revenge on you you
have a mask on so he doesn't know who
you are yeah so this whole concept of
masking on Halloween actually came from
the ancient practices during that time
another interesting holiday we found out
that has two sides is st. Valentine's
Day yeah
now st. Valentine's Day in February
falls on what was called Lupercalia and
the Lupercalia for the Greeks and the
Romans this was a time when they would
get young people together and in order
to get them into sexuality and and to
you know prepare them for marriage
they would bring them together and they
would actually allow them to have sexual
relations during
this time this is the Lupercalia and so
on this is the reason why Valentine's
Day you have Cupid who shoots you with
the arrow when you fall hopelessly in
love yeah okay
Valentine himself st. Valentine
he was another Christian bishop or
priest and he was in a sense that the
patron saint of lovest because the
Romans in ancient times they would force
their soldiers to go into battle and and
they would stop them from getting
married until after the great battles
were over and many of them wanted to get
married and they would secretly have
lovers and so Valentine would help them
and support them and so when they found
this out they arrested him and and when
he was in jail he wrote a letter to his
friends the lovers and he said from your
Valentine so so this incorporation then
comes it appears to be an innocent day
but in reality it is a day of heightened
sexuality and it is something which is
dangerous for the youth today because it
can get them into adultery and
fornication and sexually transmitted
diseases and hiv/aids all of these
things can happen unless you know they
deal with marriage and proper sexuality
now how do we bring it home because this
is a lot of information right people can
get overwhelmed like well I'm just
trying to pass a little love note to the
woman or I'm just trying to you know in
school they might have the little
sweetest cards and that and it seems so
innocent but bring it home what is the
actual when you go deeper and you see
this right the roots and what is the
danger or the outcome of all this
innocence that later
you had mentioned fornication and all
these others well what we realize with
and what Islam shows us is that you know
the Quran itself tells us well that uh
Carabas inner in the whole kanafeh he's
eaten wasabi allah he said don't come
close to adultery yeah because it is an
evil and it will destroy everything in
your life so therefore the law is
telling us he's not saying don't commit
adultery but don't come close to it
so therefore anything that can lead a
person towards you know fornication or
adultery is relationship we try to stop
this because we realize
in this case you see if a person is
going to commit murder murder is not a
natural thing to see a person killed or
a person raped that's a horrible thing
but for a man to have a relationship
with a woman for a woman to have a man
that's natural thing yeah we're created
for this yeah so therefore it's
something that the body wants to do yes
so that's why Allah said don't come
close to it
you didn't say don't do it yeah because
if you come close then you're gonna do
it yeah because you're made for this so
therefore what Islam does is that it
gives the protections so the sexuality
can come out but it will come out with
respect and especially for the young
girl she will be given you know the
place that she deserves her body is
protected her honor and dignity is
protected her family is protected and
that's really what we want and that's
the lawful marriage right now
we went from we're gonna go low and
reverse Halloween I want to just
identify with my favorite superstar
favorite comic figure hey look I'm gonna
just go from door to door and get some
candy what's wrong with that well
trick-or-treating and when I was young
as a non-muslim I trick-or-treat it yeah
and we were living in a big housing
project so we had thousands of kids
walking around
yeah with masks on and whatnot but
actually unfortunately because of the
rise of Satanism yeah in America this
time has become extremely dangerous and
people will tell you today don't send
your children out on trick-or-treating
because there's perverts and as
murderers and Satanists who actually
capture the children kidnapped them
during that time also some of the people
you would put filthy things in the bank
yeah I mean if your child is gonna beg
you know people for candy you better be
sure what that candy is yeah and so it's
a dangerous thing I mean disease can be
passed on you know so many dangers for
children that most people who have sense
won't send their children out
trick-or-treating yeah so Muslims who
are supposed to be more or organized you
know should really avoid this because we
have no relationship with that event at
all but for a person who's not a Muslim
what I say is think about it yeah don't
follow the hype don't be pushed along
yeah to do things right without
using your intelligence this is so
important today because you know even
very dangerous drugs are given names
like you know designer names and you
know things which are really dangerous
are made to seem fair-seeming and the
same innocent yes so we have to question
what is behind things and so therefore I
would say for Muslims and people of
consciousness don't be involved in the
trick-or-treating at all yeah close your
door right and don't do it I mean that's
unfortunate because if you don't if you
don't treat they're gonna trick you yeah
and we used to throw eggs on the door
right so you might get in trouble but
after a while I think most most of the
trick-or-treaters they can see a door
they know if somebody's not into it
that's again they just leave it a mess a
perfect time to get robbed oh so you got
the mascot that's right open the door
give them up that's right not that not
that the candy but the money that's
right so be safe that's right yeah tell
us now look I don't see my family all
year and it's the season to be jolly
we're getting together yeah family time
what's the problem here well this is a
great crisis for those who have accepted
Islam yeah because we are supposed to
keep relations with our families yeah it
is part of the Sunnah not to break off
with your mother or your father and to
keep your relations and so therefore we
need to be balanced some people would go
to extremes and they have nothing to do
with their families and cut them off
that's not the Islamic way yeah but at
the same time the other extreme is to
just go there and sit up there when they
eating ham and they're eating things
that are not permissible and to sit
there and to be involved in it so really
it is permissible to visit families
there's nothing wrong with showing
respect you know to your family but
Muslims need to be very clear with their
parents that they don't eat pork
they don't drink alcohol they need halal
food you know and if the family gets
together on you know an occasion like
that for most people there's no
religious part of it it's a social thing
so they get together for social reasons
you can do that but we just have to make
sure that it's halal that the food is
halal and of course no drinking of
alcohol in some cultures you have a
pudding or you know a cake that's got
wine inside of you you got to watch out
for that as well fruit cake or whatever
it is it
the culture so you know it's like a
balance it's it's it's a way of showing
respect to your family but not following
their traditions and so on I would
recommend that we still keep relations
with the family in terms of presence you
can receive presents there's nothing
wrong with that but the giving of the
presents what we tried to institute is
that we would not give presents on
Christmas but when a day comes then we
would give our family's presence to show
them that yes we are giving you we do
love you
we've given you presents but we're not
necessarily following this tradition
because this is not Islamic and it's not
even that Jesus from the followers of
Jesus peace be upon it none of them ever
come none of them celebrate any of these
huh none of these holidays these are
nature based holidays yeah it has
nothing to do with the profits so we
have to make it clear but you see for a
lot of the people in the older
generation it's tough to distinguish
this because this is a cultural thing
now yeah and it's become a North
American Western way of celebration and
family and whatnot so we have to be
sensitive to people's feelings and to
let them know that we still do love them
and we care about them but we're not
going to follow traditions which lead us
into polytheism or eating food which is
not permissible ah in Islam
so before we come to an end in just a
few more points how do we bring it home
as far as now we want to do things the
correct way so for what advice do you
have for those people who are just going
with the flow you're just letting their
desires dictate their life why is this
something so important that we mentioned
a lot of the is it safe to say pagan
roots from some of these holidays and
why it's important to really investigate
like you did instead of just blindly
following along well it's important for
people today that we have a balance yeah
you know and that we realize that Islam
is a gift that in this world of
confusion to today the last Prophet
Muhammad SAW solemn he did not come to
start a new religion but he came to
bring the final test
he gave the final version of the Quran
which actually filled in those parts
that were missing from the message and
corrected aspects of the message that
had been lost over time and so we
believe that in the teachings of Jesus
what is left there is truth in there and
the teachings of Moses there is truth
but the truth is has been polluted or
mixed up with paganism and with nature
worship and so Islam has given you a
pure straightforward way of approaching
religion and you know the straight
monotheism and so we need to really be
thankful for this and to keep ourselves
out of you know the negative practices
which have destroyed the messages of
many of the prophets who came in the
past what advice do you have for that
person who sees the contradictions he
sees the flaws he sees that you know
what the majority's religions they have
man's interpolation in them they have
man's fingerprint on it and you know
what but they're just going with the
customs now they see when they watch the
show they've met some Muslims possibly
and see you know what it makes sense
this call to worship the creator alone
to submit to him alone to do what he
wants you to do and there's nothing less
than paradise that's a simple rational
thing that's right and we should realize
that this this religion of the One God
monotheism this is something which was
practiced by all nations and the Quran
itself says we have sent verily a
messenger to every nation that they
should worship one god and stay away
from false deities and so in China and
India and Europe Africa the Americas
Middle East every nation every tribe has
received a Warner a messenger the
Prophet Muhammad peace upon them is only
the seal or the finality of all of these
prophets so when everybody's culture
there is some good
there is our monotheism there is purity
and nobody should be disrespected but we
have to realize that there are negative
forces there are forces of the devil
there are forces of paganism which seek
to defy the Creator
and take people on a course that would
lead them ultimately to Hellfire and so
on it is our prayer that our friends and
our those who are watching our program
and Families you know could all be saved
from the fire of Hell in the next life
and that we could all live in this life
in peace and security
and find the best in this world and the
hero couple more points everything
sounds good it sounds like it's
something that it's practical its
rational and there's evidence behind
what we're saying all the people have to
do is to dig a little bit but there's
some stigma attached to Islam people
seeing some things blowing up and
they're associated with Muslims they
think that Islam oppresses the woman
they think a lot of some strange
moon-god what do you have to say in
general about this to help remove some
of this new garbage that has been put
out there well what I've found is that
the the Islam itself like other ways of
life is not necessarily the same as
those who claim to be in other words in
Christianity itself there are extremists
in Judaism there are extremists in
Hinduism there as extremists similarly
those people who have Muslim names but
they're not actually practicing Islam
yeah and so it's important for people
today because today since we have
technology we are able to communicate we
we have googles we have so many ways of
bringing information and we need to go
to the essence what we call in history
primary sources go back you know as we
say take it from the horse's mouth yeah
you want to find out what something is
really about go to the source and find
out what it is then you can judge the
followers yes then you can judge an
event and say is this a Christian of it
is this a Muslim event is this a Jewish
event Islam is no different than the
other ways of life and so that is
important today for everybody to be to
have that open-mindedness when they're
dealing with each other and we don't say
that everybody has to be a Muslim
everybody has a choice the Quran says
there is no compulsion in religion truth
stands clear from falsehood and so
people have the right to choose what
they want but it's important that at
least they take
good look that is the important thing
today to respect other cultures and and
to seek knowledge to share knowledge
right so that we can all come to the
best position in life thank you very
much
may God Almighty the creator Allah
rewards you for being with us and I like
to thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the deans I hope you got to
benefit I sure did
and as our teacher and Sheikh has said
come to go to the horse's mouth and this
is the place if you like what we had to
say come back every week here to the
Dean show where we got more teachers
teaching us this beautiful way the way
of life of all the messengers of God
that way of submission and surrender
obedience not to your desires not to a
man not to a woman but the one who
created man and woman the one who
created the Sun the moon the one who
jesus prayed to the one who Muhammad
prayed to crater the heavens in the
earth and this is summed up with one
word this snap will see you next time
God willing here on the Deen show until
then I said I'm alaikum peace be unto
you
I couldn't see what everyone's talking
about who do you find one contradiction
it can't be from God but the rational
idea the rational explanation is you do
your best to give up for spring guidance
I wouldn't never give up spreading this
message okay you take that necessary
step you don't know if you're gonna live
till tomorrow so you got to find that
urgency to do the right thing right now
the reality of life usually that you
sink in until tragedy comes you get a
few bad people the media grabs ahold of
that and spends it the way they want to
if you say that you're not believe in
Jesus you have stepped outside of his
name you cannot be a muslim a that
tended our faith to to my brothers and
sisters and more your listeners whether
you're an atheist Jew or you're
Christian how can we deny the one that's
about creator the one that gave us life
he's our sustaining I would read the old
and the New Testament now read the final
al Quran has been sent to mankind that's
the source of healing and guidance
revealed to Muhammad now where this
recited by one and six people across our
sphere start your journey here and if
you're really you're sincere you come to
conclude it slams the only way to go
y'all let him know Eddie is the daily
radio show
you